RESPONDING.
SECRETARYSECRETARY POMPEO, THANK
>> HAVE A WONDERFUL EVENING,
MA’AM.
>> Martha: YOU TOO.
CENTER TED CRUZ JOINS ME.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TONIGHT.
YOU HEAR ALL OF THE CONVERSATION
AND YOU HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO CRACK DOWN ON SOME OF
THE DISINFORMATION THAT’S COME
OUT OF CHINA.
TELL ME A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
EFFORT, SENATOR .
>> WELL, MARTHA, GREAT TO BE
WITH YOU.
CHINA HAS LONG BEEN THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT GEOPOLITICAL THREAT
THE UNITED STATES FACES IN THE
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT THERE
ENGAGES IN OPPRESSION AND
TORTURE OF ITS CITIZENS.
WE HAVE ALWAYS VIEWED IT AS A
HUMAN RIGHTS OFFENSE WHEN THEY
CENTER AND SILENCE FREE SPEECH.
WE HAVE NOW SEEN AS NOT JUST A
HUMAN RIGHTS THREAT BUT IT’S
ALSO A THREAT TO NATIONAL
SECURITY AND GLOBAL HEALTH.
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS WUHAN
OUTBREAK, THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
GOVERNMENT HAS DIRECT
RESPONSIBILITY, DIRECT
CULPABILITY FOR SILENCING,
COVERING IT UP.
YOU HAD BRAVE PHYSICIAN
WHISTLE-BLOWERS BLOWING THE
WHISTLE, THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
CAME DOWN ON THEM AND SILENCE
THEM, DID EVERYTHING THEY COULD
TO KEEP IT QUIET.
HAD THEY ACTED PROMPTLY, THERE
MAY WELL HAVE BEEN A POSSIBILITY
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN CONTAINED
AS A REGIONAL OUTBREAK.
INSTEAD IT BECAME A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC.
THE LIVES LOST, MANY ARE
DIRECTLY AT CHINA’S DOORSTEP.
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE DIRECT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I INTRODUCED LEGISLATION TODAY
TO SANCTION CHINESE OFFICIALS
THAT ARE ENGAGED AND ACTIVELY
CENSORING AND SILENCING PUBLIC
HEALTH INFORMATION THAT
ENDANGERS THE LIVES OF AMERICANS
AND PEOPLE AROUND THE GLOBE.
>> Martha: THAT’S WHAT I
WANTED TO ASK YOU.
I THINK EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES THE
BAD ACTOR THAT CHINA IS IN THIS
SITUATION.
WHERE ARE THE TEETH?
HOW DO YOU MAKE IT MATTER?
HOW DO YOU CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR
WITH CONSEQUENCES, AN ACT OF
CONGRESS?
>> THERE NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
FIRST WE HAVE TO DEFEAT THIS
CRISIS.
WE HAVE TO DEFEAT THE PANDEMIC,
THE PUBLIC HEALTH PANDEMIC AND
ALSO THE ECONOMIC CRISIS.
AFTERWARDS THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CAREFUL ACCOUNTABILITY AS TO THE
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENTS IN CHINA’S
RESPONSIBILITY.
BOTH FOR COVERING IT UP AND
SUPPRESSING IT, THAT WE KNOW.
AND ALSO ONE OF THE COMMUNIST
GOVERNMENT PLAYED AN INADVERTENT
PART IN THE OUTBREAK ITSELF.
YOU ARE JUST TALKING WITH
SECRETARY POMPEO.
THERE WERE TWO STATE DEPARTMENT
CABLES THAT YOU REFERENCE THAT
OCCURRED EARLY ON THE DESCRIBED
TWO DIFFERENT LABS IN WUHAN
WITHIN MILES OF WHERE OUTBREAK
OCCURRED THAT WERE STUDYING BAT
CORONA VIRUSES.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT DOES NOT
WANT TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THEY WERE STUDYING THE
NOVEL CORONAVIRUS AND WHETHER IT
WAS AN ACCIDENTAL ESCAPE FROM
THEIR OWN LAB.
THERE NEEDS TO BE REAL
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE THE
STATE DEPARTMENT WAS WORRIED
ABOUT THE THREAT OF A PANDEMIC
FROM THESE LABS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC OCCURRED.
THAT MAY BE PART OF THE COVER
UP.
THEY DON’T WANT TO ANSWER BASIC
QUESTIONS.
I THINK THE UNITED STATES, I
THINK THE WORLD COMMUNITY NEEDS
TO INSIST ON ACCOUNTABILITY AND
CONSEQUENCES FOR CHINA’S
RESPONSIBILITY HERE.
I ALSO THINK WE NEED TO REASSESS
CHINA’S ROLE IN OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN.
FAR TOO MUCH OF OUR MEDICAL
PRODUCTS, OUR PHARMACEUTICALS,
ARE MANUFACTURED IN CHINA AND
THEY THREATEN THE LIVES OF
AMERICANS, CUTTING OFF VITAL
MEDICINES.
WE NEED TO BRING CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Martha: YEAH, I THINK, YOU
KNOW, A LOT OF WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SEE LEGISLATION AROUND THAT AND
PERHAPS INCENTIVES FOR
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES THAT
MAKE IT MORE REASONABLE TO
PRODUCE THESE DRUGS AT HOME.
THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE GOING TO
NEED IN ORDER TO CREATE CHANGE
FOR THEIR SHAREHOLDERS AND THE
BOTTOM LINE.